pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame pourquoi vous devez vous et
pourquoi je t'ai vu les médicaments
robin parce que vous savez bien que son
examen maintenant que j'ai l'impression
qu'on nous demande a tellement une
hausse et en connaissances et que je
connais seulement quelques gouttes pour
que satisfaire le immense connaissance
je le connais pas mais il faut que je
travaille que je travaille le travail et
le soir ben vi e mail qui se voulait
même pas soleil avait pas cette semaine
non non c'est certain puis nous faudrait
moi je parle 9 10 heures de sommeil si
je veux passer mon certificat ben il
faut au moins un jour à biot cinq à six
heures de noël et de se mettre à
lapproche d'examen oui avant vraiment
rester respirons vacances en
histoire-géo sa fatigue a cessé il ya
surtout des exercices de mémoire
oui puisqu'on bateau ça me plairait
c'est parce que vous dormez bouge pas la
passion je me couche à 10h30 mais je lis
encore un bon morceau de béton alors
finalement ça un peu de sommeil
oui
pas tout à fait suffisant à quelle heure
tu te lèves le matin tu te couches à
quelle heure tu as quel âge à quelle
heure le soir car ennemi est fatigué
parce qu'un musée ni nos fans de voir
beaucoup de devoirs on a beaucoup
d'heures au bout d'une année sur ce
compte il ya plein d'histoires du boost
tu es fatigué à la fin de l'année oui un
peu avec tout ce qu'on apprend parce que
enfin la fabrique de ces témoignages
bien que recueillis au hasard dans les
écoles n'ont pas valeur de preuve parce
qu'en trop petit nombre mais vous madame
vous avez fait une enquête scientifique
portant sur dix mille enfants à quelles
conclusions avez-vous abouti nous avons
pu constater qu'il y a incontestablement
ce s'il y est assurément et un large
mais aussi à l'accroissement de la
difficulté des programmes un
accroissement de la fatigue chez les
enfants et que nous avons pu voir le
nombre d'enfants fatigué dans les
établissements scolaires qui est à peu
près de 30% au niveau de la classe de 6e
atteint près de 80% au niveau des places
terminale cette fatigue des étudiants at
elle des compétences sur les plantes
issues d'imagés
certainement il s'agit en particulier de
la certain nombre de tchèques
assez intéressante assez élevé et puis
aussi le problème de l'alimentation
milieu universitaire très grave
oui les chiffres prouvent que pilier
dans l'université de paris le nombre
d'étudiants appelé ont conçu et avoir
des consultations psychiatriques même
des consultations psychologiques est en
constante augmentation
je crois que le chiffre est actuellement
d'une soixantaine par mois docteur
quelles sont les conséquences physiques
du surmenage scolaire sur les enfants le
surmenage scolaire peut provoquer chez
des enfants quelques conséquences la
première c'est la fatigue intellectuelle
fatigue intellectuelle qui se manifeste
d'abord pas d'une diminution du
rendement intellectuelle une diminution
de l'activité scolaire et qui peut
aboutir même à des troubles physiques
tels que amaigrissement fièvre facilité
de maladies intercurrente et ses
conséquences peuvent donc assez
importante
les enfants
quoique il faut travailler pour acquérir
des connaissances des ce sont surtout
les parents qui le croient et les
enfants ne peuvent véritablement arrivé
à la formation d'esprit que nous dire
hideux que nous désirons que tu il
travaille dans une atmosphère de détente
[Musique]